The resource needs of the applications include
time on the CPU, the memory that it
needs for holding its instructions and data, and
peripheral devices that it may have to access
during the course of its execution and so
on. Now, are the resource requirements of a
program known to the operating system before you
launch it? Well, yes and no. The operating
system knows enough about the program, at the time of launch, so that from the
disk, it can create a memory footprint
for this application. So for instance, on your
favorite platform, when you click on an icon, what is going on is, a piece
of the operating system called the operating
system loader is reading in the disk resident
image off that application, and creating a memory
resident image of that application. So this is
what is called the memory footprint. And the
memory footprint of the program contains the code that
needs to get executed on the processor, global
data that it might be accessing, the stack that
is needed when the program is making procedure
calls and the heap which is the dynamic memory
that it might be needing during the course of
its execution. So this is what is called the
memory footprint of the program. Then that's what is
created by the operating system loader at the point
where you click on an icon. Once a program
starts running, can the application ask for additional resources
at run time? Of course. This is exactly the
service that is provided by the operating system. For example,
if the application needs more memory, it can make an operating system call
and similarly if it needs to make a connection to access a web server it makes
an operating system call. The operating system
then performs the service on behalf of
the application and the application can then
continue with whatever it needs to get done.
That's how an operating system caters
to the resource requirements of applications. So
in other words, in addition to catering
to the initial requirements of an application
at the point of launching it, the operating system is also the broker
through which a running application can request
and get additional resources during its execution.